kevin is with us in Atlanta Georgia hey
Kevin how are you hi Dave up I
appreciate you taking my call my
question I think's a little more
psychological than it is financial I
just thought that maybe you could give
me some wisdoms that nightstick helped
me change my way of thinking but I've
been a saver just just all my life I've
never carried that other than a mortgage
and a car and my wife retired last year
and I'm about 14 months away I'll be 66
and 14 months and it's just that being a
favor all my life I've worked
construction so there's been times that
that savings has come down back and
forth up and down but the last 14 years
has been been really good and we're in
good shape
and I'm not worried about running out of
money or anything like that it's just
there's something in my head about
seeing those savings going the other
direction I mean it's like I'm going to
have to learn how to spend money and I
just it seems like the closer I get to
retirement the more it bothers me sorry
and uh my wife and I are when I retired
66 we'll bring in about 96 thousand a
year so I don't even know if we'll ever
even touch our principal unless it
becomes a medical there are medical
issues with both of us so I don't think
we're going to outlive our money by any
means and it's uh we might like said
other than maybe traveling the medical I
don't know that we'll ever even have to
touch that prayer the house and the car
are paid for now no the house we just
bought a house four years ago we owe
about 230 how much do you have in your
nest egg it's about 1.7 million good for
you wait and go Kevin
and congratulations well I appreciate
that and you said you worked
construction yes sir
what'd you do in the construction
business I'm electrical well okay so
you're like Tyson your whole life yes
sir okay where's your wife work outside
the home or did she she did she did what
achieve it she was in the insurance
business
and she's done really well I mean she's
helped big-time she actually has more
safe than I do
she always maxed out her 4:01 ever since
we first met she was actually putting a
little less into that I kind of talked
her into going full-bore so she's done
it ever since and you guys when you got
married you started with nothing yes sir
how long have you been married 35 years
okay there is you are the classic case
study of America's millionaires
well you don't feel like a millionaire
do you oh no I don't know you're almost
imagine me you know that guy that wrote
that book like that there's a difference
between having a million dollars and
somebody that can live like a
millionaire because you know we've spent
our whole life accumulating it well I
just I know way Frances the idea that a
millionaire can buy anything they want
anytime they want and the truth is
mathematically they can't write and so
living like when we say living like a
millionaire when guys like you and me
say that what we mean is super rich
people but really two million dollars is
rich but it's not super rich right but
it feels good you've done a great job
you're an inspiration to people
listening right now you know that well
it's but it's like I said it's like I'm
gonna have to learn how to spend money
up you are you are you've been there
children especially in these six years
building up one muscle you're saving
muscle yes sir and and so I would
recommend a couple of things one is is
that you put your toe in the water and
you make yourself by setting it a
written goal you and your wife that we
are going to spend X on fun and I don't
care how much it is but let me just tell
you this okay let me ask you this if you
spent uh how much money would you spend
on a cruise if you were going to take
your wife on a nice cruise and it kind
of made you feel uncomfortable because
it was it felt it felt like it's too
much almost oh well I don't know we've
been on several cruises but we go cheap
okay there's a lot in the last keep
witnesses of the questions we were not
talking about cheap I'm talking about
you're doing a good one and you're going
to do it right you're going to get a
better
and you're going to spend a little bit
more money and it's going to kind of
touch your emotions probably 4000 okay
then I want you to plan to spend $8,000
on a cruise this year okay Wow
you can't breathe now yeah I know that's
a lot but you got one point seven
million dollars dude yeah I didn't even
take the sweat off your interest yeah
that's what that's what I keep telling
myself
yeah matically amount of money it's just
those how active man you're not only on
other direction yeah mathematically I
just pulled one pair of pliers out of
your toolbox and you got 65 million
pairs in there you know yes sir that's
what we're doing and so I would never do
something put you in jeopardy you've
worked too hard but I want you to I I
didn't ask you to spend eighty thousand
did you hear that - yes sir and eighty
thousand would have been okay you could
probably still do that but but you know
let's spend eight thousand and what I'm
trying to do there is I'm trying to
stretch your spending muscle a little
bit yes sir to where you just enjoy it
and so the next time you book a cruise I
want you to better line don't go on that
cheap line go on the more expensive one
and I want you to book a better room I
want you to stay two days longer to
where you're spending eight thousand
bucks yes and you need to start working
on that that trip this afternoon when
you get off phone with me okay okay all
right because all I'm doing here is I'm
saying all right you are very good at
saving and I don't want you to get so
good at spending that you're
irresponsible that would never would
never MZ tell you do that but you're
calling me saying how can I learn to
enjoy some of this yes sir and you have
to practice yes sir and so what I'm
doing is giving you an assignment to
practice enjoying it okay and now that's
that's what she liked to do now what is
your thing what do you buy
what do you are you a tool guy a car guy
a tractor guy well I have a lot of - you
know I mean what is it that what is it
that when you are you know in your spare
time you clock I'll give you an example
I collect guns I've got a bunch of guns
I'm a gun guy okay and so I have no
reason to have as many guns as I have
except I just like them there's no
reason whatsoever
and whatever your thing is that's in
that category I want you to budget
yourself some to enjoy that just a
little bit it won't be much
okay you've always wanted this tool
you've always wanted this certain
classic car you've always wanted that
yeah there's actually a tool I'd kind of
like to have it's sort of expensive and
how much I need some how much is it me
too like a self stop yeah and how much
does it cost there about there a little
over three thousand dollars yeah okay
perfect perfect you didn't tell me three
hundred thousand I would have smacked
you silly okay no I would never do said
three thousand dollars now understand
that your income you already told me
you're not even touch the principal and
you got $100,000 your income not even
touching the principal right yes sir
okay so let's just set yourself a few
small goals like that and force yourself
to practice enjoying now let me give you
one other assignment we're going to buy
tool we're gonna go on a cruise here's
another - here's another thing I want
you to find somebody to give some money
to somebody's hurting once you increase
your generosity level I'm not saying
you're not generous but generosity goes
with spending they're kissing cousins
generous people are generally spenders
spenders are generally generous people
this is the Dave Ramsey show
you